with this appears the third relationship
of the process of this consciousness
which proceeds from the second as a
consciousness that has truly proved
itself to be independent by its will and
its deed in the first relationship that
was merely the notion of an actual
consciousness or the inner feeling of a
heart or her which is not yet actual an
action and enjoyment the second is this
actualization as an external action and
enjoyment returned from this external
activity however consciousness has
experienced itself as actual and
effective or knows that it is in truth
in and for itself but here now is where
the enemy is met with in its most
characteristic form in the struggle of
the heart and emotions the individual
consciousness is only a musical abstract
moment in work and enjoyment which make
this unsubstantial existence of reality
it can directly forget itself and the
consciousness of its own particular role
in this realization is canceled out by
the act of thankfully acknowledgement
but this cancelling out is in truth the
return of consciousness into itself and
moreover into itself as the actuality
which it knows to be true
in paragraph 223 angle is going to bring
us back to what he talked about in the
earlier paragraphs of this section these
three relationships for health Lisa in
the process of consciousness and he's
going to lay them out in a developmental
manner why are we going back to these
well you notice that I've got down here
you that we've got some possible
stopping points and he's going to invoke
this figure or character of the enemy
that's going to prove to be important in
the next few paragraphs it has something
new but that's going to be framed in
terms of the the movement of this
relationship so I've got it laid out a
little bit differently than it that it's
happening you know in the narrative of
the paragraph he starts by talking about
this what's going on right here saying
with this appears with what happened in
paragraph 222 the third relationship of
the process of this consciousness which
proceeds from the second and this is
that proceeding right ere graphically
represented it is a consciousness that
has truly proved itself to be
independent by its will and its deed at
the top its act I have got that
translated here a little bit differently
why is this so important well that we
saw in this entire second relationship
was that consciousness was engaged with
the world engaging itself reflexively
you might stay with the world but not
fully understanding its own its own kind
of tribution two things it's trying to
grasp the universal and it's trying to
do so through modes like willing that is
or desiring acting or working and then
enjoyment or consumption and then as we
saw thanks is going to enter into this
so Hegel goes on and he says in the
first relationship it was merely the
notion
in actual consciousness so you know
notion like we've said in the past
notion is what we're aiming for because
you know concept but notion can also be
something that's purely abstract at the
beginning and notice when we say that
this is abstract Hegel doesn't mean that
this religious devotion on duct is
abstract in the way that's a logic
puzzle is abstract it's abstract rather
than being deprived of any real content
to speak up so we've got a notion of the
actual vehicle Iike that is
consciousness and then we're going to
have a fair Viereck legal right and
becoming actual you might say so this is
actual but it's not fully actual and
then we have an actualization that's how
Miller translates it which I can't like
for that that Kant was a term so he says
in the first relationship was merely
this notion or the inner feeling or
heart and what's wrong with that well
it's just a matter of a fact and it's
not a matter of action or an engagement
with things so it says it's not yet
actual in action and enjoyment so the
second is in fact this this realization
or this actualization and we have
consciousness as it is involved in the
the functions of desire and work and as
we saw for hinkel these are actually not
just activities these are actually
faculties these are parts of the human
being their dimensions of human
existence in addition to desire work and
enjoyment as we just saw worked out in
the previous paragraph we also have this
function of giving thanks and that
turned out to be quite important so
there is a sort of you know possibility
of like put here losing oneself in the
giving thanks not realizing one's own
independence but if when analyze
effectively or you know in turn
the phenomenology how it actually
appears when we poke at it when we when
we shake it when we make it yield its
structure it turns out that giving
thanks involves some sort of
independence of consciousness so he says
return from this external activity that
what external activity desiring working
in enjoyment consciousness has
experienced it's something that has had
an air form as actual very good and
effective so in its willing in its
acting when isn't just doing those
things but when it starts to take note
of them and it doesn't mean necessarily
you know writing down in a diary dear
diary today I desired and willed and
enjoy etc etc etc it can be a a more
implicit process but there's a sort of
taking stock of oneself as oh yeah I am
the one who actually chose to do this I
am the one who is making this happen
making changes in the world in myself in
my relation to whatever it is that I
view as transcendent or divine so he
goes on he says it's experience itself
is actual and effective or knows that it
is in truth in and for itself I should
probably write that because it's such a
key Hegelian phrase right consciousness
in and for itself this is the end no
it's not completely unified at this
point but we're really getting somewhere
whenever you see Hegel talking about
things being in it for themselves we are
getting towards the realm spirits
understood as spirit grasped as spirit
so he goes on and now he talks about the
enemy and he says here now is where the
enemy has met with in his most
characteristic form in the struggle of
the per and emotions the individual
consciousness is only a musical abstract
moment in work and enjoyment which make
this unsubstantial
existence of reality it can directly
forget itself so there's a danger of
course if your remaining just in this in
that orientation that Hegel it called
undocked or devotion of not progressing
right so there's there's a kind of
danger or enemy involved in there of
just getting stuck not not proceeding
further in the dialectic it's a greater
danger here he is saying why well
because when you're not just sort of
sitting by yourself and praying or
smelling the incense or listening to the
wonderful music but you're really doing
things it's easy to get lost in the
doing it's easy for you to lose sense of
time it's easy as you get off task after
task after task to lose sense of the
bigger picture what it is that these
tasks are actually supposed to be aiming
after in your own role in making these
tasks happen while you're doing it
you know the desire the enjoyment the
work itself and there's also a danger
like you pointed out in the giving of
thanks as well it says in work and
enjoyment which make this unsubstantial
existence of reality with transforming
things from nothing into something it
can directly forget itself and the
consciousness of its own particular role
in this realization is canceled out by
the act of thankful acknowledgment when
you're acknowledging that that larger
transcendent Universal you can easily
forget about your own activity your own
contribution your own rule in the
process now the good news about this is
he says this cancelling out is in truth
a return of consciousness into itself so
now we're at the third relation and
moreover into itself as the actuality
which it knows to be true it knows the
truth of itself it's finally able to
articulate the truth of itself in a way
that it can now respond to and and grasp
this third relationship in which this
true actuality is one of the terms is
the relation of that actuality as a
nothingness to the universal being the
process of this relation we have yet to
consider
paragraph 224 is one of the shortest in
the phenomenology of spirit and so it's
it's worth spending a little bit of time
on that an awful lot there is something
very interesting going on here not
something that we haven't seen come up
before this relationship between
nothingness and and being but it is
being stressed in a very important way
that in the next paragraph you're going
to see the the real meaning of that that
play itself out so he's talking about
this third relationship and he says that
this third relationship has two extremes
in you know in the translation its terms
but excitement in German so it's good to
keep that in mind in part because in the
passages you have to come Hegel is going
to talk about something like a syllogism
so extremes means mean something in that
sense now it remarks about the human
being that we just saw imperative in the
past paragraphs you know grasping itself
as being independent and as a true
actuality of our octa very type and
we've seen this interplay between
activity you know or you know action
twin and very tight actuality and now
it's grasped itself as a actuality that
possesses truth that that is truthful we
can play off this in a number of
different ways you know if we want to be
very clever truthful truth containing
truth you know providing truthful about
itself you know in a reflexive way but
here's the real upshot it says that it
becomes aware of its relationship to the
universal being as a nothingness a
negative kite in relation to the
universal being or we could say essence
if you want to the visa so you know what
is what is putting out in here that's
that's telling us about what's happening
in this this relationship and
by saying the process of this relation
we have yet to consider to be toxic you
know so that's going to be very central
does this play between nothingness and
being how does that play itself up what
is it to be aware of oneself as a
nothingness and a nothingness in
relation to something else that isn't -
nothing this
to begin with as regards the
contradictory relation in which
consciousness takes its own reality to
be immediately a nothingness its actual
doing thus becomes of doing of noting
its enjoyment a feeling of its
wretchedness work and enjoyment thus
lose all the universal content and
significance for if they had any they
would have a being of their own both
withdrawal into their mere particularity
which consciousness is set upon reducing
to nothingness consciousness is aware of
itself as this actual individual in the
animal functions these are no longer
perform naturally and without
embarrassment as matters trifling in
themselves which cannot possess any
importance or essential significance or
spirit instead since it is in it is in
them that the enemy reveals himself in
his characteristic shape they are rather
the object of serious endeavor and
become precisely manners of the utmost
importance does enemy however renews
himself in his defeat and consciousness
and fixing its attention on him far from
freeing itself from him really remains
forever in contact with him and forever
sees itself as defiled and since at the
same time this object of its efforts
instead of being something essential is
of the meanest character instead of
being a universal is the merest
particular we have only we have here
only a personality confined to its own
self and its own petty actions a
personality brooding over itself as
wretched as it is impoverished
paragraph 225 is exploring the first
implications that come to light of this
relationship in consciousness
consciousness as a nothingness in
relation to universal or absolute or
whatever we think about it as being or
essence base and Hegel is going to talk
about this as a contradictory or better
perhaps put a post and Gagan Gazeta
relation that is going to be explored in
this one and then in the rest of the
paragraphs to come and he says in this
relationship consciousness takes its own
reality to be immediately on nothingness
so we're dealing with reality and he
doesn't say if you're plate cut here he
says reality tat and this is supposed to
be immediate so of course you know when
we see immediacy we should always be
thinking great what what's going to
happen next in this paragraph we're not
going to see the next develop we'll see
that in the paragraph and paragraphs to
follow what he's sketching out here or
outlining is the way in which
consciousness at first appropriates this
this being a nothingness and he's going
to say that it's actual doing and it's
enjoyment don't turn out to be what they
were in the last few paragraphs what we
saw in the development was that by doing
things by enjoying by desiring
consciousness came to be aware of not
only its own existence but its own truth
its own importance here it's leading to
the the opposite says it's actual doing
becomes a doing out of nothing and the
the preposition that put there in German
is is font right so a do a fun Dixie
catch right so doing it that's stemming
from nothing and if you want to also
read those it's not doing anything
that's another way that you could read
it but it's really more about the agent
in this case or you know
yeah doing nothing the enjoyment leads
to instead of actual enjoyment to a
feeling of wretchedness that's how
Miller's translating it wouldn't look
one look is unhappiness the unhappy
consciousness so it is becoming
distinctly aware of its own unhappiness
as consciousness in its attempt to
provide itself with enjoyment so that
whole progress of desire
you know geared up were our minds or
taught you know I'm doing and enjoyment
good news it's all sort of unraveling
and coming apart or it's not unraveling
in its structure it's unraveling in its
meaning
the person is saying well what does it
matter if I choose things or if I enjoy
I'm not enjoying the absolute I'm not
enjoying the universal I'm just this you
know nothing and what kind of enjoyment
is that no it's not of course totally
nothing because nothing isn't able to be
unhappy but that's escaping the this at
the moment so I says they lose work and
enjoyment lose all the universal content
and significance that's the key there
the the bottom drops out the person
keeps on working and then they say what
the hell am I doing this for what is the
point you know and this happens to many
people in contexts not just necessarily
this one but many other contexts where
there's a crisis of meaning even
enjoyment think about how many things
people set themselves up to enjoy or
consume and then find out that their
expectation does not meet up to or
rather exceeds the reality of what it is
that they experience and they say you
know I thought I would take this person
out for a wonderful dinner and then we
would have wonderful conversation and
instead you you go out and the waiter
spills the wine and there's people you
know chattering in the background
turns out that whoever you ask them
isn't really that interested or is it
compatible in certain ways and the
lighting isn't great and we can go on
and on and on and you could multiply
instances like this you know it doesn't
have to be quite so expensive or
ambitious as that you click on you know
series in Netflix because you've heard
good things about it and now you're
going to fin to watch it because you've
got a whole weekend to do it and you
watch the first few episodes the writing
is really good it's promising and then
it just goes downhill and you're left in
that project well should I keep on
consuming this keep on enjoying it or
should I turn it off and find something
else to do and you sit there and you
watch some more just in case it might
get you know get itself back at track or
get better and after a while hours have
gone by Netflix asked you are you still
watching this are you okay over there if
you click that still hoping for it to
get better everything we could go on
right we can multiply examples of what
we're calling here losing and sort of
universal content and significance to
work and to enjoy now he says these
withdrawn to their own particularities
which consciousness is set upon reducing
to nothingness notice that that is
consciousnesses or an activity there its
own work is reducing these things to
nothingness now he shifts gear he talks
about consciousness becoming aware of
itself as this actual individual in its
animal functions it's tier Liga and
Hegel uses the term you know functions
there so you know what he has in mind or
you could serve the very basic things
eating drinking eliminating waste moving
from place to place hunting I suppose or
ferreting out food breathing sleeping
you know and start adding in other
things the whole realm of sexuality
insofar as it has to deal with just
bodies by itself laying in the Sun
enjoying ourselves you know
in blankets you know there's all these
things that we can we can sort of build
up and the upshot of this in this
passage is that consciousness is
becoming of itself and it's becoming
aware of itself as a nothingness in
terms of these animal functions so you
could say that the reason why
consciousness has lost its universal
significance whatever it did have it is
that it realizes itself as just this
sack of meat and bones that does these
things that in the past could be sort of
overlooked because they were just
trivial or natural right they're not
really that important I've got the
German passage here that is particularly
good he says that you know they're there
on them for Zeke right in and for
themselves nice tea that is there there
there you know unimportant
you know Miller has trifling in
themselves and then that's not quite
exactly what cable-stayed saying he
didn't in for themselves they're they're
negligible is another good way to put it
right and they have kind of isn't
legally the title in the basally they
have no importance and they have no
essentiality is a way that we could
translate these they don't have any real
being they don't matter right until they
do and then once they do now we have
this embarrassment this shame this
seriousness they become a preoccupation
for us and if you think about it you
know the process of aging for her many
of us or even you know just just not
that becoming particularly old but just
moving into adulthood
we become more and more preoccupied with
our own bodily functions and how to
prove them and regulate them and am I
getting sick to have you know something
that I found out WebMD bad place to look
by the way you know what should i do
what urine should I wear how should I
you know make the hair on my face
actually look halfway decent you know
you can go on and write we actually in
the situation that we occupy of late
McGarity are not totally in relation to
previous eras but it's been intensified
we have entire industries that have
existed now for over a century that are
just hammering this point home that you
need this you need this you need this
that all has to do by the way with with
work desire and enjoyment right in
interpersonal relations we you know sort
of riff on this for quite a while but I
don't I don't want to because I want to
go on so we become aware of ourselves in
our animal functions and he says that in
its in them the enemy reveals himself in
his characteristic shape and so they
become the object of serious endeavor
and become precisely manners of the
utmost importance now what is he talking
about there we could deter put this in
several different ways the enemy could
be something like the devil when people
are you know living at a religious
existence and they're trying to aspire
to the divine which is that that
universal that transcendent the
unchangeable they're unable to to grasp
it why because the devil keeps them
preoccupied with the filth and mire of
the existence that they occupy right now
keeps putting lascivious and dirty
thoughts in their head or the devil
keeps you know causing them bodily
illness that distracts them from that's
a you know prayers or whatever but it
doesn't necessarily have to be framed in
such a context it could be praying just
in terms of consciousness we are the
consciousness of orissa portion of
consciousness is itself the enemy it's
not something coming in from the outside
and something within us something that
holds us back the part of us that you
might say rebels in the nothing
that we really are that that it has a
morbid obsession with that or wants to
just continually stress that point
look you are nothing right so he goes on
and he says the this enemy if we try to
defeat it renews himself in his defeat
consciousness in fixing attention on him
far from freeing itself from him really
remains forever in contact with them and
forever sees itself as defiled so in
trying to overcome the enemy you remain
bound to the enemy and according the
enemy and the you know bodily animal
functions is this great importance of
saying that they're serious matters one
may actually makes oneself to be stopped
dealing with those as serious matters
this is an experience of one's
nothingness but one's nothingness as you
might say disgusting something this
rather than as a nothingness even being
a periodic necessity better than that
one would think but it is it's sort of
reaching an impasse here so he says that
consciousness ends up you know in so the
object of its efforts instead of being
something essential winds up being of
the meanest the lowest character it
winds up spending its time with things
that are trivial things that are
worthless things that are not going to
get it any closer to the the absolute to
the things that really matter and so he
says instead of being a universal
consciousness is the merest particular
we here we have here only a personality
confined to its own self and its own
petty actions a personality brooding
over itself and he talks about it as
being wretched and impoverished right
these are terms that are going to come
up in the next paragraph it is it is it
is wretched or unhappy this morning look
Lee right and it is also an impoverished
it
an experience of resource lessness of
not having what it needs to have being
our music being poor and so this entire
thing is sort of a thumbnail sketch of a
dynamic that a person can very easily
get caught in the question that at this
point is is consciousness going to
remain here in boys spinning its wheels
spinning around the wheel or is it going
to proceed on to something else
but to go through these moments the
feeling of its wretchedness and the
poverty of its actions is linked the
consciousness of its unity with the
unchangeable for the attempted direct
destruction of what it actually is is
mediated by the thought of the
unchangeable and takes place in this
relation to it
the mediated relation constitutes the
essence of the negative movement in
which consciousness turns against its
particular individuality but which quad
relation is in itself positive and will
bring consciousness itself to an
awareness of its unity with the
unchangeable
paragraph 226 begins by picking up with
these two connected experiences the
feeling of wretchedness and the poverty
of actions that consciousness is
experiencing as the way in which it is a
nothingness in relation to the the
unchangeable the essential the universal
that which has importance that which has
genuine being and the terms here are you
know a pretty straightforward The Fool
zionism looks you know fueling of its
unhappiness feeling that's misery its
wretchedness and poverty of actions
Ihram the zionists winds of it's doing
the fact that it's doing doesn't have
any seeming purpose or or any meaning
and significance it doesn't certainly
doesn't have the significance that the
unchangeable or universal does or
doesn't this is where now we're going to
see a bill start to turn things on their
head he says both of these two both of
these moments is length the
consciousness consciousness is unity
with the unchangeable how is that well
what is negative is going to turn out to
be positive and so I've got this sort of
you know thing going the sweep happening
here there's a sense of difference or
distance from in fact even though
infinite difference or distinction from
yeah unchangeable you know I'm so
unworthy but when one is evaluating that
one is actually using the thought of the
unchangeable and as part of what is is
evaluating it sort of like you being use
as a criteria for evaluating wiring the
stuff on this side isn't meaningful or
valuable at all so the destruction of
what consciousness is and it's doing and
it's it's a striving and in all of its
modalities is carried out by means of
using these the essential or the
universal
changeable in one's thought as a kind of
mediator right so this is trying to be
quite important says it's mediated by
the thought of the unchangeable and it
takes place in this relationship so now
the question is how should we interpret
this mediated relation and Hegel gives
us two different ways
the mediator relation constitutes the
essence of the negative movement in
which consciousness turns against its
particular individuality right so far
that's what we've been seeing
consciousness is sort of tearing at
itself it's as he said brooding or you
know it's unable to rest it in anything
importance going through these
modalities of unhappiness and poverty
but at the same time as a relation Hegel
says that this is positive why because
there really is a connection not just a
bear connection but a connection of
unity with the thing that the unhappy
consciousness is so many happy about
being disunited from namely the
unchangeable the essential the universal